this is based on your life I mean this
is things yeah
loosely gram no but things like isn't
the washing machine that happened to you
what the washing you were very hungover
oh yeah tell Jodi Foster back story all
that stories are really cool oh great
when I was teaching this is what this
show is based on I I went home one
weekend and I was in my 30s I was
probably 33 years of age I went home to
see my mother and then I went back and
while I was at home my mother did my
washing for me because I was only 33 and
I went back on the on the Sunday night I
got really drunk and then I went for a
curry and then the next day I went into
school I'm going to I went into school
and it was a school in Slough and it was
quite a rough school but they had a
really brilliant hearing-impaired
Department so they were hearing impaired
kids who you know struggled they were
they were really looked after in school
anyway I was really hung over I went
there and I bet break time I felt really
uncomfortable I thought something's not
right so I went to the toilet and I
pulled my trousers down and some of my
mother's knickers got I've got mixed up
in the washer and I was wearing my
mother's
all right oh god now oh I remember going
are you lose and this is such a low
point you [__] loser
and then the Korean food the curry and
the booze kicked in from the night
before so I I did like a fecal Jackson
Pollock I'd say guy Oh God not this like
this as well oh Jesus
so I clean myself up I pulled my
mother's pants back went back into the
classroom and I saw one of the hearing
impaired kids looking at me like this
that's what I remembered that my I had a
microphone directly
so maybe man down isn't that far-fetched
there you go how are you reduction Tony
Michael you know like that
and then I will his belly went in my
mouth